what you mean by Quantum Supremacy and
how it should be used maybe how it
shouldn't be used what are your thoughts
for the audience about a term that you
coined many years ago well I think one
of the most remarkable things that we
understood about the difference between
Quantum and classical systems is what I
made reference to earlier when I spoke
of the quantum Church touring thesis we
think that in general and efficiently
simulate a Quantum system using any
classical system I think that's one of
the most interesting things we've ever
said about how Quantum is different from
classical and so there's a strong
incentive to try to validate that a
laboratory in a real experiment to the
extent that we can and so I suggested
that as a challenge for the field to do
experiments which indicated that we
could do something with the quantum
device which surpasses what we could do
with our most powerful classical
computers and I called that Quantum
Supremacy
[Music]